[Music]
the suspect in a mass murder on the
loose this Thursday night the man hunt
for a gunman after America's worst mass
shooting this year this is someone that
should not be approached what happened
at a bowling alley in a restaurant our
Jackson frco is in Leon Maine a city
under
lockdown gin Hospital overwhelmed with
injured
children and a Canadian Israeli on the
front lines reflects on children left
orphaned suspended the first NHL player
Iced Out For Sports
scambling global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us we begin with events
unfolding in Maine tonight where police
and the FBI have surrounded the rural
home of a suspect in a mass shooting a
man described as armed and dangerous an
intensive Manhunt has been underway for
the past 24 hours for that suspect after
18 people people were shot and killed in
a bowling alley and a restaurant in Leon
Maine that's about 24 km from this home
which police have now descended upon
Leon is a city of about 40,000 people
they've all been warned to shelter in
place the suspect is 40-year-old Robert
card an army reservist who it's reported
spent time in a mental health facility
this summer our Jackson prco is in Leon
Maine tonight Jackson do we know what is
going on at that
house
Donna that house is just a few
kilometers from where I am right now and
it seems as though the FBI and police
have uh found good reason to search the
home they may believe that the suspect
is in there although that's not clear
that he actually is but they are
proceeding cautiously shouting commands
into the home uh telling people to come
out with their hands up for example uh
the Department of Public Safety saying
this is standard procedure but clearly
something has brought them to that home
at a time when this community and the
surrounding areas remain under strict
stay-at-home
orders Lewiston Maine is on lockdown
eerily quiet as residents are told to
stay put and hide in their homes the
whole back of our house was just lit up
with lights from police ambulances we
heard sirens and helicopters all night
there's an expansive police Manhunt for
a gunman still on the run and still
considered a serious threat he should be
considered armed and dangerous
based on our investigation we believe
this is someone that should not be
approached Wednesday's massacre unfolded
in the most unlikely of places a small
town bar and a bowling alley where it
was practice night for the town's Youth
League I of nowhere he just came in and
there was a loud pop and he was holding
a weapon I just booked it um down the
lane and I slid basically into where the
pins are and climbed up to the machine
and was on top of the machines for about
10 minutes until rovs got got there
things like this don't happen in Leon
Maine Dan Holmes lives behind the
bowling alley when he heard about the
shooting he grabbed his kids and his gun
and headed to the basement I feel like
if if a lunatic is out shooting random
people that might give my family a
chance the suspected gunman is
40-year-old Robert card a member of the
US Army Reserves he previously reported
mental health issues and allegedly
threatened to shoot up a Guard base he
was committed to a mental health
facility for 2 weeks during the summer
knowing true Robbie it's just a lot
going on in his head he's got a lot of
problems up in his head right
now one of them's uh uh schizophrenic
police recovered what they call a
vehicle of interest but aren't saying
much else about where they believe card
may now be until he is caught this
community cannot begin to mourn I'm so
deeply saddened as is every one of the
1.3 million people of this this
beautiful
state and as we look at the activity
outside the suspect's home main State
Police are saying that while they are
not positive the suspect is in the home
they are doing their due diligence Donna
this has been such a hectic and
stressful day here not only because of
the tremendous loss but police time and
time again have stressed the threat they
believe the suspect poses both because
of his access to weapons and his history
of mental health problems all right
Jackson prco on that man hunt in Maine
thank you this started just before 700
p.m. last night with the first 911 call
about a shooting at that bowling alley
at 7:08 reports of a shooting at schmi
bar and grill a 12-minute driveway about
an hour later police released photos of
an armed suspect and tell people to stay
inside with the doors locked at 9:17
they release photos of a vehicle they're
searching for and just before 11: they
named Robert card considered armed and
dangerous as a person of interest
despite all the mass shootings in the US
there is no playbook for what happens in
the aftermath and with the suspect still
at large loved ones of the Dead can't
even begin to grieve or understand how a
night at the bowling alley could end so
horrifically Mike Armstrong on what we
know about the people who were
killed as police look for Clues locals
are looking for answers it's a crime
that seems impossible to understand I
mean having mental issues whatever I
deal with mental issues every
day and it's not one of the things I
would think to do Wednesday night is
practice for the children Patrick Pand
and his son skipped bowling Wednesday
they'd normally be there but Pand says
his brother a youth bowling coach was
inside he heard a pop he turned to the
kids and said actor shooter um and he
was right near an emergency exit so I
believe he hurted them out that door but
as far as I know he's uh he doesn't know
how he's going to unsee some of the
things that he
saw the Carnage is it's terrible now the
first victim identified from the bowling
alley ran a youth bowling league
76-year-old Bob Violet was a retired
Sears mechanic he had three sons and six
grandchildren his family says he was the
sort of person person who wouldn't let
someone leave a room without a hug and a
kiss on the cheek also killed was Trisha
Asim she was a golfer and a sports fan
she worked at the bowling alley but
Wednesday was just there to play with
friends Joey Walker was shot to death
Leroy Walker's son was killed at the
attack at shmi's bar he's been told by
Witnesses Joey died a hero he picked up
a a butcher knife from somewhere as you
know they he has all that stuff near the
bar anyways
and he tried to go at the gunman to stop
him from shooting anybody else the
gunman shot him twice twice through this
everybody
pray pray for those that are hurt pray
for the
families that have a loss as shocked as
everyone is there are locals who say in
a country with so many mass shootings it
wasn't a matter of if but when that
violence would visit even there small
town Mike Armstrong global
news now to developments in Israel and
Gaza Israel's military the IDF staged
what it calls a tactical operation in
Gaza overnight it released this video
tanks infantry and armored engineering
units going into Northern Gaza an
Israeli military spokesperson says
threats were neutralized and a few hours
later Israeli forces withdrew the
promised fullscale incursion has yet to
happen tonight a seventh Canadian has
been confirmed dead two others are still
missing gazin are into the 20th night of
Israel's Siege and with only a trickle
of Aid trucks getting in hospitals
already struggling to treat a deluge of
patients are barely hanging on a warning
the details are disturbing and some of
the images are graphic here's Jeff
simple a small child trapped under the
rubble after an Israeli air strike
Health officials in Gaza which is
controlled by
say 22 Palestinians were killed when
this house was hit incredibly the child
survived he was then rushed to a
hospital that's run out of
medicine even iodine is not available we
don't have anything in the hospital so
what can we do they come here to die in
the hospital due to lack of treatment he
says Israel says it's targeting Hamas
but the collateral damage is plain to
see a local cameraman recording video
for Global News found this Hospital full
of
children stay with us shouts this boy to
another after he suffered a head injury
too graphic to
show all we did was live our normal
lives his father says ask anyone in the
neighborhood we are
innocent there is a severe shortage in
food there's a shortage in fuel there's
a shortage of medication this un worker
says another 12 trucks of humanitarian a
was allowed to enter Gaza Thursday the
UN says at least 100 trucks are needed
every day to meet the essential needs of
gaza's 2 million residents and
critically these shipments do not
include fuel when all of the Power Runs
Out do you know what what you will
do I cannot even imagine what what will
I do ail Musa is an aspiring Palestinian
journalist she was on a short list for a
British University scholarship before
October
7th she says nine m members of her
family were killed Wednesday when her
cousin's house was hit the generator
powering her refugee camp was also hit
the light we call it lint without power
or fuel she's running one light off of
this one battery we already run out of
power and this battery maybe it it will
just uh help us for like the coming
hours only and most importantly she says
they need electricity for clean drinking
water so we cannot uh fill these tanks
so there's no
water even the water being sold is
polluted and is undrinkable yet we are
forced to drink because we're thirsty he
says Israel says it won't stop bombing
until Hamas releases all of its more
than 200 Israeli hostages Hamas says
around 50 of those prisoners have
already been killed by Israeli air
strikes Hamas says the death toll in
Gaza over the past 3 weeks has now
climbed to more than 7,000 for his part
us President Joe Biden says he has no
confidence in those numbers in response
Hamas just released this list containing
nearly 7,000 names as well as their age
gender and ID number Global News hasn't
independently verified this list Donna
Jeff simple in Jerusalem thanks Jeff
Israel's prime minister has said he
intends to annihilate Hamas in Gaza and
allout confrontation that is feared will
be long and bloody our Danielle hamam
spoke to a Canadian Israeli who is a
member of Israel's Special Forces and a
warning some of the details and the
images in her story are
graphic East Jerusalem predominantly
Arab and under Israeli
control ask people here about Gaza and
they say the world is not listening ask
them how Hamas should be dealt with and
they'll turn you away afraid of Israeli
reprisal a lot of friends happen to them
y
things on the social media they arrested
them directly mhm they are not giving
anyone a chance
to to share the
reality if there is a military solution
to crush Hamas it seems the Israeli
Defense Forces are about to show the
world what it might look like these are
our homes these are our families that
they came and they attacked
us Captain N as we've agreed to call
call him is a Canadian Israeli who's
part of a Special Forces
Unit he also has a 1-year-old son I'm
going to ask you as a father what
happens to a child who is seen his
parents bombed I don't know how to
answer a question like that as a father
it it hores me to the soul that
horrendous tragedies are happening on
both sides but when I think of a child
who is growing up without parents I also
think of E Israeli children who are
growing up without parents who will be
growing up without parents because of
what happened on October 7th if you look
at Iraq and
Afghanistan history has taught us that
when bombs fall on civilians inevitably
you radicalize a new generation of
militants has that crossed your mind at
all we're being very decisive very
thoughtful about what we do and how we
do it and what the consequences of our
actions will be and those images coming
out of Gaza does he look at them on one
hand I really try to do my best not to
it hurts it really really hurts and it
affects me on an emotional level uh I'm
a human being we're here to protect on
the other hand he says Hamas can no
longer be allowed to exist but for some
Israelis it's not a simple case of good
versus evil I think that BB is evil BB
is evil because is using people not as
human but as things for his
purposes
professor says Benjamin Netanyahu BB for
short has spent years effectively
tolerating even facilitating Hamas in
order to remain in power killing the two
states solution giving them funding in
one way or another in order to keep them
there in the Gaza showing to Israelis
and the whole world that there is no one
to speak to on the Palestinians side
there are still people here including
the professor who believe peace one day
is possible but only in a future that
doesn't include Hamas or Netanyahu Donna
Danielle hamam Jin in
Jerusalem no one can escape Gaza right
now and no one is allowed in if it
weren't for the work of local
journalists there the world would not
see the impact of the Israeli
bombardment many of those journalists
and their families are
dying
this is alzer's bureau chief in Gaza yel
Dadu burying his wife daughter son and
Grandson today they've been seeking
shelter in central Gaza and were killed
in what Al jazer says was an Israeli air
strike eight other extended family
members also died the committee to
protect journalists says its preliminary
investigations found 24 journalists have
been killed since the Hamas attack on
October 7th 20 Palestinians three
Israelis and one Lebanese journalists
says are making great sacrifices to
cover this heartbreaking conflict all
parties must take steps to ensure their
safety an Ottawa NHL player in the
Penalty Box for what he did off the ice
coming up the trouble he's in for sports
gambling the NHL has suspended Ottawa
Senators player Shane Pinto for 41 games
for violating the the League's gambling
rules it's the first time the league has
banned a player for sports betting since
online gambling was legalized in Canada
and the US Mackenzie gray breaks down
what we know about what the player is
accused of
doing he's one of the Ottawa Senators
brightest stars but Shane Pinto won't be
on the ice for at least half the season
after the NHL handed him a 41 game
suspension for gambling we're 100%
behind Shane um we'll be here for him um
we'll get offer him any support that he
needs and we'll welcome him back with
absolute open arms but the details of
the ban aren't clear the league says
their investigation found no evidence
that Pinto bet on NHL games which is
banned under the League's collective
bargaining agreement but players are
allowed to gamble on non- NHL events I
don't really understand when they say
okay didn't bet on hockey are you
allowed to bet on other sports
technically you are so I don't really
get it all we don't think we know the
whole story pindo is the first player
suspended over
gambling
yes that's that that way bud since the
NHL started embracing sports betting in
2018 something the Senators also
welcomed last season when they became
the first team in the league to have a
gambling sponsor on their helmets these
ads groom Children and Youth uh into
gambling and some of them become
addicted to gambling suspensions for
gambling have been prevalent in other
sports with 10 football players banned
for violating the NFL's policy and if
more isn't done experts believe gambling
could be a bigger issue than doping I
hope that a case like this really drives
a level of awareness of the issue of
gambling in sport and the risks that
athletes face Pinto has apologized for
his actions but they'll likely cost him
hundreds of thousands of dollars Donna
as he still doesn't have a contract with
the Senators for this
season okay McKenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks McKenzie destructive and deadly
ahead what hurricane Otis did to
Mexico's Southern Pacific
[Music]
Coast
the hurricane that hit Mexico as a
category 5 storm has killed at least 27
people it ripped apart aapo including
high-rise buildings in the tourist areas
about 80% of hotels are affected roads
are under water and electricity has been
knocked out it developed so quickly
people had little time to prepare
authorities were caught off guard there
has been some looting from stores
including one where National Guard
officers allowed people to take
perishable food prime minister Justin
Trudeau has announced a three-year pause
on the federal fuel surcharge on
deliveries of heating oil the new policy
is aimed mostly at Atlantic Canada where
many homes are heated by oil and where
many provincial liberals including the
premier of new Finland and Labrador
Andrew Fury have been complaining about
federal taxes on home heating
oil the highest proportion of uh people
with home heating oil across the country
are in Atlantic Canada and that's why
this hit them particularly hard as the
provincial pricing systems were replaced
by the federal pricing system the
temporary pause on the fuel search
charge begins in two weeks it's expected
to save the average household using
heating oil
$250
London and that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna freezen
tonight's your Canada is Fogo Island
newfinland and Labrador we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
global.com and thanks for watching I'll
see you back here on Monday
[Music]
bye-bye